Oh, my gosh.
Hello? Hello?
Huh? Hello.
I wonder why
so many people are here today.
Yeah, right. You're right.
You're here for me or for me.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
That's not. We're not doing this.
We're not doing this.
You didn't
if you listen against me
again, some people in the favor
and I'm saying that this
is the start of Russia.
Okay.
Well, you are doing
you are making it one step further.
It's been seven months.
You've now called on the message
that does not rain down on times.
Welcome back.
Welcome.
Welcome to the press briefing room.
Okay.
All right, let's go.
Are you ready?
Are we going to behave?
While many folks
the on on plays.
Sorry to our guests.
We apologize. Yes, I apologize.
I apologize.
Okay. Well, many.
Well, many folks here in U.S.
are focused on March Madness
or the World Baseball Classic.
Go Team USA tomorrow night.
By the way,
we at the White House
today are going to focus on another sport
which is soccer
or football,
as some of my guest might say,
specifically AFC Richmond.
And I can neither confirm nor deny
the existence of the believe
the banners
that we're seeing around
that you all may be
seeing around the White House
complex today.
It is an honor.
It is truly an honor
to have Coach Lasso here with us today.
On a serious note, though,
because this is actually very serious
for the reasons that they are all here,
Jason and his classmates.
And there's a real message
around mental health
and they are meeting with the president
and the first lady.
As you all know
this afternoon on this important topic.
And as you know,
the president has made mental health
the centerpiece of his unity agenda.
And I know that
Jason wants to share a few words.
And so Coach Lasso, the podium is yours.
I appreciate you do. Thank you.
Yeah, I.
I truly
did not know it was going to be this one.
When?
On the way here,
until we're out here.
And so thank you for taking an interest.
And I know you're here
for bigger reasons than us,
but I just want to say
that on behalf of myself,
everyone here with me today
and the numerous other folks that
that it takes
to make
our show Ted Lasso,
it is sincerely an honor
to visit the White House.
And I had the opportunity
to speak to the president
and to the First Lady
about the importance of mental health.
So, like, no matter who you are,
no matter where you live,
no matter who you voted for,
we all probably I assume
we all know someone who has
or had been
that someone ourselves actually
that's struggled,
that's felt isolated,
that's felt anxious, that has felt alone.
Right.
And it's actually one of the many things
that.
Believe it or not,
that we all have in common
as human beings. Right. And so
that means that
it's something
that we can all,
you know,
and should talk about with one another
when we're feeling that way
or when we recognize that in someone
feeling that way.
So please,
you know,
we encourage everyone and it's a big
theme of the show is like to check in
with your
you know,
your neighbor, your coworker,
your friends, your family
and ask how they're doing
and listen
sincerely, you know,
I mean,
you all ask questions for a living,
but you also listen for a living.
So, you know, who am I preaching to?
The choir that is okay.
And look and while
while it's easier said than done,
we also have to know that we shouldn't
be afraid to ask for help ourselves.
And that does take a lot,
especially when it's something that has
such a
negative stigma
to it, such as mental health.
And it doesn't need to be that way.
And if you can ask for that help
from a professional, fantastic.
If it needs to be a loved one.
Equally as good in a lot of ways,
because it's
sometimes you just need
to let that pressure that
that pressure valve release.
The president is working on
and is in his own team,
although his team is real,
our team is make believe.
I don't think I don't know that
despite what the people at FIFA
and I will tell you,
we are actually a make believe team.
But, you know,
they're working very hard to make sure
that, you know,
that option is available
to as many Americans as possible.
Now, look, I know in this town
a lot of folks don't always agree.
Right.
And don't always feel
heard, seen, listened to. Yes.
But I truly believe that
we should all do our best
to help take care of each other.
That's that's my own personal belief.
I think that's something
that everybody up here on stage believes.
And that's things
we talked about in the writers room,
we talked about in the editing room
and everything in between.
And just like, you know,
want to emulate,
you know, these make believe folks
that we all play at AFC, Richmond
and the way they take care of
one another.
That is the wish fulfillment of the show.
Aside from me playing coach
and these guys
being professional footballers,
you know, that's like,
you know,
that's, that's,
that's a big part of the show.
Now,
I can't help but take this opportunity
to take at least one question for please.
Yeah.
Are we all on the air
the way you decorum, right?
That's the word we're using. Decorum.
Yes, sir.
Familiar face, high threat, grim
and fake journalist.
Yes. Trent, nice to see.
How do you feel about Kansas City
being one of the named hosting
cities for the 2026 World Cup
here?
I was hoping for a softball.
Okay.
You know what?
I'm very excited to be told.
Yeah, Kansas City
going to be one of these teams.
I mean, I love this town.
What I am genuinely worried about is
once we get all these folks
from all over the world
to come to Kansas City
and see our city, eat, our food,
our people,
you're going to have,
you know, a lot of folks
that will want to move away.
That's what we're about.
That's it for us. All right.
Thank you very much.
See you guys.
Thank you
sincerely so much for having us
and putting up with us.
Now on to a greener pastures.
Thank you.
Thank you, guys. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
Thank you.
Excuse me,
I'm Joe Biden and now I
got the real one here now.
Yeah.
No, I need I need fake
teeth and,
you know,
injected with a lot more hoods, but.
Okay. All right.
Thank you so much, guys.
Thank you so much.
Thank you. Thank you.